tink tink tink tink flashlights the
whole room is dark except for our
flashlights faces of all it is the last
episode in October and the lights are
out this episode is brought to you by me
undies you know it's spooky having
underwear that isn't three times softer
than cotton me undies has new patterns
every month of underwear and now they
have lounge pants made from the same
micro modal fabric as their underwear
three times softer than cotton to get
15% of your first pair and shipping and
free shipping go to me undies that's meu
n di es comm slash Jenna Julian check it
out you will absolutely not be
disappointed also guys this skin is a
sponsor this week why would you wait to
get on Twitter or watch TV to get your
news do it with the skin they send you a
nice neat tidy email every single
morning it's a newsletter just for you
so you can educate yourself and it's
completely free whoo go to this game
that's th es ki mm ComStat annejulien
that's two M's check it out subscribe
it's completely free and you enter to
win a $250 Visa gift card when you do
that I'm scared and excited why is this
so fun that's why I know it's what I
said it's like okay so first of all you
have to give a big shout out to Selena
Delta
Horo who left this comment in our last
podcast what we asked for we wanted to
know something that would be scary and
fun for you guys for the last week of
October and she suggested when I read it
I was like no way because this is a book
that I used to have and we kept it in my
cottage and my dad's house and I would
read it and it would scare the absolute
[ __ ] out of me mm-hmm like my brother
would not even read it when she said it
I was like I have not heard that name of
that book in ages and it's called scary
stories to tell in the dark it came out
in 1981 so this is something that I read
like all of them have you read any of
these oh okay I have read zero of them I
read like one sentence when we were
looking it up 10 minutes ago but you
might have like heard some of these
stories because they're like the prefix
it like American folklore okay so you
read them when you were a kid and you
were probably you were not the first
generation I'd be like reading them as a
kid okay so we also Julian would you
like a challenge yeah we are allowed to
jump scare one another at any point
during this podcast successfully or
unsuccessfully stop disappearing come
back okay yeah that's part of the fun so
we can jump scare each other so this can
basically just not even be us reading
scary stories it could be one of us
distracting the other while they're
setting up this elaborate scare prank
this is no longer a podcast that's a
prank channel welcome in gone scary City
dududududududududu okay you know what is
in the middle of something scare you yes
okay okay you ready yeah are you gonna
start
okay like I wanted this to be like an
aesthetically fun and scary pop oh so
you're just like coughing and like
scaring me in general come back all
right we get it
that's fun sorry okay so I haven't I
literally have not read these since I
was a child so I don't know if they're
gonna be scary anymore but I'm excited
are you Julian I'm excited yeah I feel
you should I have the light on my face
while I'm not really easy to scare each
other because when you're shining a
flashlight under your face towards your
face it is incredibly difficult to see
peripherally yeah are we gonna be blind
after this episode yes it's fine the
first story Julian of scary stories to
tell in the dark is called the big toe
are you ready ready okay
a boy was digging at the edge of the
garden when he saw a big toe he tried to
pick it up but it was stuck onto
something so he gave it a good hard jerk
and it came off in his hand then he
heard something groan and scamper away
the boy took the toe into the kitchen
and showed it to his mother it looks
nice and plump she said okay she nasty
I'll put it in the soup and we'll have
it for supper
okay that's that's what hello lady I
just have to say this artwork is so
nostalgic like it just it literally
brings you back to reading this in the
dark like in my room my cottage when I
was scared of our work can I say
something
okay Julian go ahead speaking of artwork
last episode I promised you I would put
pictures of a doll on screen and I never
did I'm sorry
thank you for apology the name of the
website to find the pictures of the doll
because I'm not gonna put it on this
episode either Kevin
okay sick and also if you wanted to
download the PDF file for this story and
read along you can do it at Harper
HarperCollins right that's where we got
this yeah it's a PDF file okay yes with
all of that out of the way that night
his father carved the toe into three
pieces and they each had a piece then we
think are a human toe right yes then
Julie oh my god that was like you kicked
my chair and it felt so weird and Wiggly
then they did the dishes and when it got
dark they went to bed the boy fell
asleep almost at once but in the middle
of the night a sound
awakened him it was something out in the
street it was a voice and it was calling
to him where is my toe it groaned the
boy pulled the blankets over his head
and closed his eyes I'll go to sleep he
thought when I wake up it'll be gone
spoken like someone who really just out
here eating people's toes yeah they're
all way too comfortable where is my
topic Road then the boy heard footsteps
moved through the kitchen into the
dining room into the living room into
the front hall then slowly they climbed
this stairs
closer and closer they came soon they
were up in the upstairs Hall now they
were outside the door where is my nose
mainly because it was violent and it
hurt jump-scare the voice groaned his
door opened shaking with fear he
listened as the footsteps slowly moved
through the dark towards his bed
they stopped where is my toe the voice
groaned at this point you've got it
[Laughter]
[Music]
it literally says in the story at this
point pause then jump at the person next
to you and shout really I'm gonna get
you back alright go for it you tell your
reading off of my phone yeah okay well
this one this next one's called the walk
w okay it's about a guy who makes pad
thai every night Julian it is not no
it's called the walk like normal spelled
wal K my uncle was walking down a lonely
dirt road one day okay he came upon a
man who was also walking down that road
mm-hmm scared already the man looked at
my uncle and my uncle looked at the man
the man was scared and my uncle was
scared of that man but they kept walking
and it began to get dark the man looked
at my uncle and my uncle looked at the
man the man was very scared of my uncle
and my uncle was very scared but they
kept on walking story they kept on
walking and deep down into the woods
they went it was getting darker wait
they're walking together and the man
looked at my uncle my uncle looked back
at the man the man was terribly scared
of my uncle and my uncle listened was
Jerry
all right that's it that's all three
it's like every time you flash your lady
to me like you have to use all of the
resources you have okay like climb this
is uh that's the story it's just it said
now screams that's it yeah they just
like had a staring contest
I can't believe a staring contest yeah
well it was it was a delivery babe I'm
doing the next one because I wanted to
go again Julie don't don't I don't like
that can birds be skinwalker save her is
Pat I tied her
this one's called what do you come for
there was an old woman who lived all by
herself and she was very lonely me
sitting in the kitchen one night she
said hmm I wish I had some company no
sooner had she spoken then down the
chimney tumbled two feet from which the
flesh had rotted okay the old woman's
eyes bulged with terror and two legs
dropped down the chimney as well in a
body gang
two arms yeah body I'm sorry I'm trying
to turn it up I want to win there's a
big prize involved sorry as the old
woman watched the parts came together
into a great gangly man the man danced
around the room faster and faster he
went then he stopped and looked dead
into her eyes
what do you come for
she asked in a small voice that shivered
and shook what do I come for he said I
come for you
wowthat's as you shot the last words
stamp your feet and jump at someone
nearby oh okay well it looks like I had
missed my timing a little bit on that
one pass this over to you okay so you
can touch each other
you can lunge at each other can be
violent
you can even scare someone while you're
at that picture these drawings one of
those rights we're at like actually the
goal I was very very immersive guys get
out of here okay back back to it alright
this is called me ty Doty Walker I don't
understand I really don't want to come
up here dog I'm coming you know there
was a haunted house where every night a
bloody head fell down the chimney at
least that's what people said nobody
would stay there overnight then a rich
man offered $200 to whoever would do it
Wow there's definitely like a many
youtubers that would line up to take
that gentle inch am i right mm-hmm
feel free and this boy said he would try
if he could have his dog with him so it
was all settled smart boy the very next
night the boy went to the house with his
dog to make it more cheerful he started
a fire in the fireplace then he sat in
front of the fire and waited and his dog
waited with him for a while nothing
happened but a little after midnight he
heard someone singing softly and sadly
off in the woods
the singing sounded something like this
meat I don't eat what it's just somebody
singing the boy told himself but he was
frightened
then his dog answered the song softly
and sadly it's saying then chicken she
called moly dingo dingo the point could
not believe his ears his dog had never
uttered a word before then a few minutes
later he heard the singing again now it
was closer and louder but the words were
the same meat i do' t walker
this time the boy tried to stop his dog
from answering he was afraid that
whoever was singing would hear it and
come after them but his dog paid no
attention and again it's saying lynn
cheek in cheek kali molly dingo dingo a
half an hour later and the boy heard the
singing again now it was in the backyard
and the song was the same meat i dog
walker and again the boy tried to keep
his dog quiet but the dog same outlaw de
louder and louder than ever lynch EKG
called the mali dingo dingo soon the boy
heard the singing again now it was
coming down the chimney meat i dog
walker and the dog sing right back
Lynn chicken she called him Molly dingo
dingo suddenly a bloody head fell out of
the chimney he was missing the fire and
landed right next to the home the dog
took one look and fell over dead from
fright the head turned and stared at the
boy slowly opened its mouth and that's
what I was supposed to scare you but I
didn't goddamnit is scary when you lunge
at the other person right because you
can't see just the flash lights in your
face so it's like ruining your
peripheral vision kind of have that / if
you know like what the hell is that
story I used to read that when I was a
kid it's creepy yeah it's creepy enough
to the idea of bloody head rolling down
a chimney are you kidding me the idea of
body parts falling down the chimney and
then forming into a body and then
dancing that's the second story with a
part of a body coming down a chimney ok
this looks like someone was like what
are kids like Santa alright let's mess
with that I'm gonna scroll a little bit
down
a lonely pair of pants what the no what
are you doing
you got it you can't scare me while I'm
reading okay there once was a boy alone
after school he had just gotten new
pants and they weren't yet comfortable
so he walked and he walked until one big
step he hurt his pants ripped because he
didn't have Mike Romanow fabric of the
me undies lounge pants that you can buy
right now by going to me undies dot-com
slash Jenna Julianne their lounge pit
what's up there lounge pants are just as
soft as their underwear just as
convenient but they are just their pants
they're wonderful they're wonderful to
sleep indoors they're wonderful to watch
TV in the ways of the game in their
wonderful the podcasts in and scare your
partner and seriously the lounge pants
are perfect for this time of year when
it starts to get a little cool you want
to be by the fire but the underwear is
just not gonna cut it
okay so once you get your me undies get
your me on these long pants they're here
they're like so soft you won't even
believe how soft where when you touch
them also guys if you want all of the
stuff that me and these offers the fun
prints on their underwear the socks the
bra let's the lounge pants and you want
it for a better price than anybody else
then you can get yourself a me undies
membership with their 100% satisfaction
guarantee
if for some reason which it won't happen
but if it does you don't like any of
their undies they'll do whatever they
can to get you the right pair and if
they can't they'll refund you they're a
great company they've been supporting
the podcast for a long time and it is
spooky to think about not having me on
DS so right now if you look in your
undies drawer just imagine seeing the
most comfortable undies in the world
also the most good-looking ones so just
go to me undies comm slash gender
joining that's ME und IES comm slash
trying to join and get 15% off your
first pair of lounge pants and grab
yourself
some awesome me and he's always there
and the consider subscribing to be a
member because you get great prices and
it is worth it check it out it is a
no-brainer click the link below or go to
that URL Thank You me Elise was there
she go there she go
one thing that's honestly pretty scary
is not being informed in today's day and
age oh the skin helps prevent that when
you wake up in the morning the skin is
waiting for you and your email inbox is
a nice beautifully organized newsletter
about all the news for you that happened
in the world that you need to know about
to be a functioning member of society
okay you can't not know what's going on
in the world and thrive whoa you're
getting really close you're getting
really close well you did grab my leg
but I did the burp defense guys the skin
is a really easy newsletter to read
there's no nonsense
there's no jumbled opinions there's no
commercials it is just the skin it keeps
you up-to-date on literally everything
you need to know with voting with
everything in politics with sports with
world news good or bad you need to be in
the know the skin helps you do that so
go to th es ki mmm the skin calm /
annejulien and subscribe it's completely
free okay just try it
if you don't like it that's fine but you
got to try it because I think you will
also guys a lot of the podcast sponsors
that we have our products right like you
have to pay money which is great because
you're getting a good product but this
skin is completely free
okay so it requires none of your money
so check it out go to the URL below the
skin calm so chant of Julian and
subscribe to the newsletter so you like
it and also you're entered to win a two
hundred and fifty dollar Visa gift card
and that's real money that could be in
your pocket just from subscribing so
check it out thank you to our sponsors
in moving on
this one is called he heard footsteps
coming up the cellar stairs who this
pictures creepy there are all creepy
pictures Ted Martin and Sam Miller were
good friends he spent a lot of time
together on this particular night they
were sitting on a fence near the post
office talking about one thing and
another there was a there was a field of
turnips across the road suddenly they
saw something crawl out of the field and
stand no it looked like a man but in the
dark it was hard to tell for sure
mm-hmm pen but soon it appeared again it
walked halfway across the road and it
turned around and went back into the
field then it came out a third time and
slowly started walking towards them
mm-hmm by now Ted and Sam were scared I
forgot you had headphones on I was
trying to snap in your ear that did not
work okay bye now Ted and Sam were
scared I'm scared and they started
running but when they finally stopped
they decided they were being foolish
they weren't sure what they had seen or
scared them so they decided to go back
get a better look pretty soon they saw
it for it was coming to meet them mm-hmm
it was wearing black pants a white shirt
and black suspenders Wow Sam said I'm
gonna try and touch it
why then we'll know if it's real he
walked up to it don't peered in its face
do that it had bright penetrating eyes
sunk deep in its head skin maka looked
like a skeleton
Ted looked at one and screamed
and again he and Sam ran but this time
the skeleton followed them they got to
Ted's house they stood in the doorway
and watched it it stayed out in the road
for a while disappeared a year later Ted
got sick and died toward the end
Sam sat up with him every night the
night Ted died Sam said he looked just
like the skeleton yeah the end sorry so
maybe it was him the whole time Irv's
just a really mean thing to say to your
dying friend or the skeleton went into
him when he touched him
yeah that's Kelton probably killed him
yeah like how they just glazed over that
he died yeah a year later he died all
right well the end your turn
coldest cold is clay a farmer had a
daughter for whom he cared more than
anything on earth she fell in love with
a farm him named Jim but the farmer did
not think that Jim was good enough for
his daughter to keep them apart he sent
her to live with her uncle on the other
side of the country he had a kid soon
after she left Jim he got sick and he
wasted away stories yeah if you pardon
me yeah julienne him like the laziest
scary story book you've ever read and
then he died yeah
it's just the end of every story soon
after you left or after she left Jim got
sick and he wasted away and died
everyone said he died of a broken heart
the farmer felt so guilty about Jim's
death he could not tell his daughter
what had happened she continued to think
about Jim and the life they might have
had together one night many weeks later
what why are you laughing Julie okay yes
that's very funny
one night many weeks later kertzer there
was a knock on her uncle's door don't
piss off the dogs when the girl opened
the door Jim was standing there your
father asked me to get you he said I
came on his best horse is there anything
wrong she asks I don't know he said she
packed a few things and they left
she rode behind him clinging on to his
waist soon he complained of a headache
it aches something terrible he told her
she put her hand on his forehead
why are you cold as clay she said I hope
you're not ill and she wrapped her
handkerchief around his head they
traveled so swiftly that in a few hours
they reached the farm the girl quickly
dismounted and looked knocked on the
door her father was startled to see her
didn't you send it for me
she asks no I didn't he said she turned
to Jim but he was gone and so was the
horse they went to the stable to look
for them the horse was there it was
covered with sweat and trembling with
fear but there was no sign of Jim
terrified her father told her the truth
about Jim's death then quickly he went
to see Jim's parents they decided to
open his grave the corpse was in its
coffin
but around its head they found the girls
Hey ha ha
it was a fake around he kept
why'd you put your phone right there to
set an alarm to try and scare me yeah
beat you can't scare me okay oh my god
I've already gotten scared like 12 times
that is so scary I used to read a story
when I was little about like a girl that
had a used to wear a choker and then one
time some guy untied it and her whole
head fell off and I wear chokers all the
time Beach if you take it off my head
goes oh damn you know what I'm saying
okay this one's called what was the name
of the last when you read cold is called
okay shine NAT are your face the
timberwolves around French Creek had
gotten out of hand there were so many
wolves the farmers could not stop them
from killing their cattle and sheep so
the state put a bounty on them it would
pay a hunter $10 for every wolf pelt he
turned in a butcher in town named Bill
Williams thought aliens thought that was
pretty good money so he stopped working
working as a butcher and started killing
wolves he was good at it every year he
killed over 500 of them that came to
more than five thousand dollars has
quite a bit of money in those days after
four or five years bill had killed so
many wolves that there were hardly any
left in that area so he retired and he
vowed to never harm another wolf because
wolves had made him rich then one day a
farmer reported that a white wolf had
killed two of his sheep he shot at it
and hit it but the bullets didn't have
any effect soon that wolf was seen all
over the countryside killing and running
killing what nobody could stop at cattle
and sheep one night the white wolf came
into Bill's yard and killed his pet cow
bill forgot about his decision to never
harm another wolf he went into town the
next morning
bought a young limb for bait took it out
to the hills and tied it to a tree and
he backed off about 50 yards and sat
down underneath the tree with his gun in
his lap he waited so many wolves though
it's hard to when the bill didn't come
back his friend started looking for him
Julian Julian okay
finally they found the lamb they was
still tied to a tree it was hungry
it was alive then they found bill he was
still sitting against the other tree but
he was dead his throat has been torn
open and there was no sign of a struggle
his gun hadn't been fired there were no
tracks in the soil around him that's for
the white wolf it was never seen okay
stop what up just like baby the tail
makes you feel like usually an
earthquake or something like actually
scary not just you clomping around
that's how an Aries scares scary sees
this scary season beach do you like it
yeah sorry I'm scared though what do you
think the white wolf was doing it killed
him but how how did the white wolf just
slit a man's throat I don't know he used
his wolf hands he might be a skinwalker
can walk I don't touch me like that on
my own is a skinwalker No
this story is called the haunted house
one time a preacher went to see if he
could put a haunt to rest at a house and
his settlement I don't know what that
means so I think it's like settle a
ghost thing mm-hmm haunt arrest yep
the house had been haunted for about 10
years several people had tried to stay
there all night but they would always
get scared out by the haunt so this
preacher took his Bible and went to the
house went on in built himself a good
fire and little lamp sat there reading
the Bible weird flex but on
right then just before midnight he heard
something start up the cellar walking
back and forth back and forth it sounded
like somebody trying to scream and got
choked off yeah like that then there was
a lot of thrashing around and struggling
and finally everything got the old
preacher took up his Bible again but
before he could start reading yards
footsteps coming up the cellar stairs
he sat watching the door to the cellar
and the footsteps kept coming closer and
closer he saw the doorknob saw the
doorknob turn and when the door began to
open he jumped up in hollered what do
you want the door shut back easy like
and there wasn't a sound the preacher
was trembling a little but he finally
opened the Bible and read a while then
he got up and laid the book on the chair
and went back to mending the fire then
the haunt started walking again step
step step up the cellar stairs the old
preacher sat watching the door saw the
doorknob turn in the door open it looked
like a young woman he backed up and said
who are you what do you want there's
this dope drawing
oh [ __ ] she's scary too the hot sort of
swayed like she didn't know what to do
then she just faded out the old preacher
waited waited and when he did hear any
more noises he went over and shut the
door he was sweating and trembling all
over but he was a brave man and he
thought he'd be able to see it through
so he turned his chair to where he could
watch and sat down and waited it wasn't
long before he heard the hearts haunt
start up again
step step step closer and closer step
step-step it was right at the door the
preacher sit up and how this Bible out
before him then the knob slowly turned
to the door opened wide this time the
preacher spoke quiet like he said in the
name of the Father the Son and the Holy
Ghost who are you and what do you want
the
came right across the room straight to
him and took hold of his coat it was a
young woman about 20 years old her hair
was torn entangled the flesh was
dropping off of her face so he could see
the bones and parts of her teeth she had
no eyeballs but there was a sort of blue
light way back in her eye sockets
he had no nose she had no nose on her
face then she started talking it sounded
like her voice was coming and going with
the wind blowing she she told how her
lover had killed her for money and
buried her in the cellar
she said if the preacher would dig up
her bones and bury her properly she
could rest then she told him to take the
joint and joint of the little finger
from her left hand and lay it in the
collection plate at the next church
meeting and he'd find out who had
murdered her and she said if you come
back here once more after that you'll
hear my voice at midnight and I'll tell
you where my money is hid and you can
give it to the church the hot sobbed
like she was tired and she sucked down
to the floor and was gone the preacher
found her bones and buried them in the
graveyard the next Sunday the preacher
put the finger bone in the collection
plate and when a certain man happened to
touch it it's stuck to his hand the man
jumped up and rubbed and scraped and
tore at the bone trying to get it off
then he went to screaming like he was
going crazy while he confess to the
murder and they took him on to jail
after the man was hung geez I guess that
was the punishment after the man was
hung the preacher went back to that
house when midnight and the hearts voice
told him to dig under the hearth Rock he
did that and he found a big sack of
money and where that haunt had held onto
his coat the print of those bony fingers
was burned right into the cloth and it
never did that picture was very very
scary it was really scary I would if I
was a kid and I saw that picture while
listening to the story wow dude I'd be
out II by the way we're gonna link where
you can find this
book below because we're like totally
using it is fun means don't repeat what
do you think the ball what do you think
the BBA story what do you think the blue
light can we stop the scaring thing no I
like it what do you think the blue light
was behind her eyes no her soul why it
just seems like an odd detail to include
I'm ready to get scared you scare me oh
this one's called yeah that's not the
name of it yeah it's called the guests a
young man and his wife were on a trip to
visit his mother usually they arrived in
time for supper but they had gotten a
like a little bit late start and I was
getting dark so they decided to look for
a place to stay overnight and just go on
in the morning just off the road they
saw a small house in the woods
maybe they'd rent rooms the wife said
till they stopped to ask an elderly man
and woman came to the door they didn't
rent rooms they said but they would be
glad to have a stay overnight as guests
they had plenty of room and they would
enjoy their company the old woman made
coffee and brought out some cake and the
four of them talked for a while then the
young couple were taken to their room
they again explained that they wanted to
pay for this but the old man said he
would not accept any money the young
couple got up early the next morning
before their hosts had awakened on a
table near the front door they left an
envelope with some money in it for the
room and they went on to the next town
they stopped in a restaurant had
breakfast
mm-hmm when they told the owner with
where they had stayed he was shocked
that can't be he said that house burned
to the ground and the man and woman who
lived there died in the fire the young
couple could not believe it so they went
back to the house only now there was no
house
oh all they found was a burned-out shell
Mullin
they stood staring at the ruins trying
to understand what had happened then the
woman screamed in the rubble was a badly
burned table like the one they had seen
by the front door on the table was the
envelope that they had left that morning
how was a good story that was a short
one I'll read another one the girl who
stood on a grave some boys and girls
were at a party one night there was a
graveyard down the street and they were
talking about how scary it was don't
ever stand on a grave after dark one of
the boys said the person inside will
grab you he'll pull you under that's not
true one of the girls said it's just a
superstition I'll give you a dollar if
you stand on a grave said the boy but
Greg doesn't scare me so the girl I'll
do it right now the boy handed her his
knife stick this knife in one of the
graves he said no that was this some bad
friend you were there the graveyard was
filled with shadows and was quiet as
death push me I'm trying to get creative
hard to scare you or just sitting next
to each other there's nothing to be
scared of the girl told herself but she
was she was scared she picked out a
grave and stood on it then quickly bent
over and plunged the knife into the soil
and she started to leave but she didn't
get away something was holding her back
she tried a second time to leave but
couldn't move she was filled with terror
something has got me she screamed as she
fell to the ground when she didn't come
back the others went to look for her and
they found her body sprawled across the
grave ok without realizing it she had
plunged the knife into her in through
her skirt that she had pinned to the
ground only it was the knife that held
her she had died of fright
oh damn so she like pinned herself to
the grave and just died of getting
scared gee I thought that was gonna be
like that was like the amount of like
realism to that one was scary you know
because it was like she just like
freaked herself the [ __ ] out and stabbed
her dress into the ground and then
literally scared herself to death oh my
god what do you think of that one who
are you in that situation because I'm
definitely does not that girl I'm the
boy being like don't do that all right
I'm trying to look for ones that like
look familiar to me the hook I know
scared me a lot when it was a little
yeah
Donald and Sarah went to the movies they
went for a ride in Donald's car ooh the
ends they go on a day oh yeah okay they
parked up on a hill at the edge of town
from there they could see the lights up
and down the alley
Donald turned on the radio and found
some music but an announcer broke in
with some news bulletins a murderer had
escaped from the state prison he was
armed with a knife and was headed south
on foot he his left hand was missing in
its place he wore a hook let's roll up
the windows and lock the door said Sarah
that's a good idea so Donald that prison
isn't too far away said Sarah maybe we
really should go home but it's only a
ton of clocks that Donald I don't care
what time it is she said I want to go
home
Sarah clearly is a Virgo okay that's not
right look Sarris adult he's not gonna
climb all the way up here why would he
do that even if he did all the doors are
locked how could he get in Donald he
could take that hook and break through a
window and open a door she said I'm
scared and I want to go home Donald was
annoyed girls are always afraid of
something he said Donald's a jerk okay
as he started the car Sarah thought she
heard something or someone scratching at
her door
here that she said as they roared away
it's not like somebody was trying to get
in
oh sure said Donald soon they got to her
house would you like to come in and have
some cocoa she yes no he said I've got
to go home
he went around to the other side of the
car to let her out hanging on the door
handle was a hook the end it scared me a
lot when I was little because you know
what that's a realistic a story and I'm
scared yeah can you not understand why a
little girl be I can understand why a
child would be scared of that for sure
like some of them like okay that's a
little ridiculous like somebody's head
falling down like yeah that's really
scary but that one was like real and
it's like genuinely scared me that's why
I remembered it yeah that's what I'm
saying like the realer ones not the ones
where someone just turns into a skeleton
they're dead like it's the ones where it
like could happen here mm-hmm
you could go stand on a grave and
accidentally stab your dress into the
ground and then die overnight a fright
that's the thing that could happen mmm
so it's scary okay do you want to talk
more about the hook okay do you want to
hear something funny
when I was a kid I watched a scary movie
yeah and it scared the [ __ ] well cuz I
had jumps well yeah cuz and I cuz I
hadn't seen most of the movies it was
making fun oh I was just I didn't seen
like the you know scream or whatever may
I carry your basket oh come on that's
Queen sorry Sam Lewis spent the evening
playing chess at his friend's house
it was about midnight when they finished
their game he started home mmm what a
rollicking night of chess outside it was
icy cold and quiet as the grave
oh he playing footsie with me boy I
skated you like that guy who played
footsie with the woman who didn't want
to play footsie so they had to land his
flight
dammit guys the problem he's a problem
as he came around a turn in the road he
was surprised to see a woman walking
ahead of him she was carrying a basket
covered with a white cloth when he
caught up to her he looked to see who it
was but she was so bundled up against
the cold it was hard to see her face
good evening Sam said what brings you
out so late she didn't answer and he
said may I carry your basket she handed
it to him from under the cloth a small
voice said and I was followed by wild
laughter I mean riding I bought you
screaming my name all right juicy all
right keep going
Oh Oh you grab my calf and it was really
[Music]
my story okay sorry
anyway she goes ha ha ha it was the
larger than life JC chasse left chasse
that is AJ Sam was so startled that he
dropped the basket did you hear that I
rolled a woman's head he looked at the
head and he started the woman it was her
head he cried and he started to run and
the woman in her head began to chase him
soon the head caught up to him how was
the head running okay it bounded into
the air and sunk its teeth into his left
leg grabbed his by grabbed him by the
teeth
Sam screamed with pain and ran faster
but the woman and her head stayed right
behind soon the head leaped into the air
again and bit into his other leg they
were gone okay the head comes back falls
down the chimney when you flashed your
flashlight eyes and this one that's too
many flashlights he goes to tend to his
fire when he grabs a piece of wood and
puts it in the fire it was her head he
wakes up this whole thing was a dream he
realized he realized they shouldn't have
skipped band practice and he did and he
knows that next practice tomorrow and
goes into school and gonna be ridiculed
for skipping band practice because it's
very close to the homecoming game it's
very close to the homecoming game and
he's not gonna be prepared a couple of
days later Friday rolls around he's
unprepared it's been it's the it's the
opening game homecoming and he's
expected to be lead in the band he shows
up walks out onto the field and in the
March don't-don't-don't
he's doing fine because it's just
walking in formation that's the easiest
part he gets out into the center of the
field looks out into the crowd and only
sees one person in the audience it was
the woman with no head he says what are
you doing here he runs away he trips and
falls slams his head on the pavement
wakes up in a hospital in the hospital
there's a TV on the basketball game is
playing he looks his fourth quarter two
seconds left the three-pointers shot the
three-pointer goes up it
not a basketball it's the woman's head
it drains through the three-pointer the
Celtics win except no one's asking
questions by they're playing a
basketball game with someone's head he
rolls out of bed he was faking the whole
time he's not even sick all the nurses
start attacking him he jumps through the
window barrel rolls onto the floor
stands up and says nothing because he
gets attacked by the head again it falls
from the sky it won't stop chasing him
then the head grows wings like the
little thing they play Quidditch with it
just got wings it's chasing him around
he does three backflips all of a sudden
he's just as scared as he was but there
was there was an Olympic recruiter right
there and saw him do the three backflips
was then hey kid you did some grazy
backflips will you come be on our team
and competed the Olympics he turns
around he says to the head do I have
your movement permission to leave this
story now and go be an Olympics and she
says yes and then he goes off to the
Olympics and the head the head was his
mom he the head was his mom and packed
him lunch with her teeth I feel like I
had a little bit of spice a little bit
of flair you know what I mean because
we're not six sometimes these stories
are a little flat it's okay though
because we're getting in the spirit no
no I know they're nostalgic but you know
it's any sense
oh god that's your foot that's your foot
are you scared or what I'm scared
wait so this is okay so this episode
concludes it will be the last episode of
October meaning it will be it will be
the Halloween episode yes grand finale
we're in finale that is if we made it
this far
[Music]
the noise is scary every single like we
were in when we were in Colorado every
single thing that we saw in the middle
of the night we just pretended was
possessed and just made that noise I
hate that I would I asked you to stop
like a thousand times
yeah and that would have done nothing
for calling because he would have kept a
scares me you walk up to the cabin it's
dark you open the front door oh boy here
we go
and there's Garfield I think you can you
say hi Garfield Garfield looks up in you
and goes oh hi welcome to my cabin
yeah welcome to Chili's hi we're rolling
out to find those country's greatest
diners drive-ins and dives wait stop
putting this away
that's a scary story you reach for your
phone and there's just an invisible hand
pushing it away that's terrifying
so what was your favorite story scary
I'm scared mine was the one where they
stay at the motel or the little bit in
breakfast but that doesn't exist that's
like a scary concept to me that's pretty
scary pretty [ __ ] scary scared are
you scared yeah what if we looked out
front and there was two men sorry Julie
the other one was just a head it was the
woman's head from this side enough with
the head I didn't start it I just
finished it alright I hope you guys are
good and scared this was fun
Julian you definitely got scared a
couple times a guy you a couple times
but I think that you won in this Gary
why cuz I was more violent with touching
the table and making noises yeah you got
me a couple times
sure well this was fun it was festive
and spooky and fun and nostalgic at the
same time but not for you cuz you know
but I remember being scared as a kid so
it's nostalgic in that way
anyway I hope you guys have a wonderful
Halloween we're gonna scare the [ __ ] out
of every kid we see just kidding we're
not we're gonna give out candy and I
hope you guys have a great time be safe
going to Halloween parties
please use lift or don't drive or walk
or plan because there's a crazy night
out there kids out there hopefully you
guys have a wonderful Festivus a
Halloween and we'll see you guys next
week for another episode of the Jenna
Dewan podcast this time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]